this is one of the writers direct
director to write and producer of the
gallows he's my age I'm not his little
brother I just realized how much I don't
like you
tremendous nightmare theater is gonna be
a quarter-mile of twists and turns long
hallways passageways no elevators 18
different platforms and landings this is
the largest haunt in Fresno and the most
haunted and people that have seen the
movie the gallows are going to actually
find themselves in some of the scenes
people of Fresno are gonna be able to
experience the gallows live and in
person here at the Fresno Veterans more
- Auditorium on the stages in the
hallways in the wardrobe room the places
you saw in the gallows are right here
and that's what you're gonna face in
tremendous nightmare theater experience
the most haunted place in Fresno where
they filmed the gallows tremendous
nightmare theater I don't want to be
mean but we have a height difference
right now yes this is clear it was all
go down it was elegant thinks that
accident had no I heard you deleted a
lot of sexual content from the movie
this is very true why would you do that
for the demographic you're trying to
appeal to you know we're trying to get
that wholesome Midwest experience and
you know they can be a bit touch I'm
from Nebraska I know oh well I'm from LA
and I auditioned for you I have a range
of emotion for the nudie sexual stuff
well I can be emotional during those
scenes - okay see the real-life I'm very
emotional during those things hey guys
Ryan right here so today we're gonna be
helping promote the gallows we're gonna
be going through the Haunted Mansion
based off of it you might recognize a
couple people I'm with right now hey who
are you guys
that's right that's right Veronica here
she was also invited to help capture
this Haunted Mansion experience
I meant theater for the longest time I
tried getting on the schmoes no channel
ever since I was at thirty thousand subs
170 thousand subs later I finally was
able to get on there was a question I
would ask and I'm gonna ask it to these
guys right now so guys yeah you have to
blow to go on schmoes I mean yo ya
marquel is probably Margaret Ellis rich
Marla oh my god I first went as far as
the gallows
this is where all the deleted sex scenes
took place this is the other writer
director producer of the gallows how are
you I am old old older than people think
so maybe I shouldn't say anything okay
you're still pretty good-looking you
should be in front of the camera thank
you
you shouldn't be I'll take that camera
I'll take that thank you always wanted
to do it on the stage in front of an
audience this is Tina
and Alyssa Tina right here Melissa right
here yeah you see there are pretty girls
who can work at Warner Brothers
apparently a compliment in there I'm
about to do a vine with evan breen what
a dick that's the famous rope the
gallows it's also the same design for my
sexual fetishes no that's a makeup done
it's strange just looking at you while
you do this it's like I'm very much
aware you're not coming on to me
why'd you take one of my french fries
without my permission because I was
hungry dude dude you took all my ketchup
well I'm sorry
you said you're gonna get sweet potato
fries but you got regular fries I got
regular prices I want a regular fries
didn't put enough salt on it dude unlike
crisps cut fries but I want a potato
fries yeah you know what man will I have
the seasoned salt you took too many
fries I can enjoy your makeup smearing
off your face right now I don't want you
in their face do it so right now we're
on the car trip Veronica
and the star from the gallows her so
Mekhi Phifer over here she's a wonderful
singer give us a taste of your singing
voice
beautiful beautiful be on Broadway
so Pfeiffer yes we're gonna go through
the haunted maze of the place where you
filmed this movie are you actually
scared to go through this maze even
though you spent so much time filming in
there you know what I actually am scared
really oh yeah because they always have
some new trick up their sleeve and
they've been anxious to what do you
can't trick like who they're always yeah
they always like outdo themselves so
it'll be it'll be interesting to see
what they come on like I know it's gonna
be very I know I'm scared
I seriously hurt people when I'm scared
like I will hit someone in the face
I'll back into someone really really
hard I have one testicle now I am so not
scared I am cuz I'm not a [ __ ] how he
just said she's not a [ __ ] oh my god
Cody Krishna going first representing
the schmoes know in the gallows ain't
strapped in normally I just know what
it's like to have a strap on you know
what I mean
trying to make it strap on Joe
guys I got my GoPro I'm scared so I
can't say the word [ __ ] when I'm in
there apparently so before I can this is
good footage it's just great footage all
right guys let's go do some parkour
let's do this
for all the scares my girlfriend is
behind
guys just did Mays based off the gallows
that scared the crap out of me that
really scared me so oh man and what's
cool about it is the writer director and
producer it's two of them they actually
are the ones who are in charge and
running this whole maze so the actual
filmmakers the creators are the ones who
have created this maze for us so you're
getting this horror movie directors to
actually create a horror movie maze they
didn't just hire someone else and throw
in effects that were similar to the
movie so you really do get an experience
based off of the film totally recommend
it totally worth going out to Fresno to
check it out so yeah and I'm sweating
balls right now so I should go
scarers scarers Skinner's bookies are
the faces of the actual scarers
everywhere what's your name Maria
Clara's Josh Hansen manager and have a
channel yeah and to be vlogs just check
it out like silly
my name is Shane what's the name matches
what was it the actress
you